[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros en 5
minutos nos acompañan yolanda kakabadse
de administra de ambiente de ecuador y
ex presidente de wwf internacional
gracias por acompañarnos y con la
bienvenida también le preguntó
recientemente una convocatoria de
emprendedores que mostraron sus
proyectos para dar acceso a agua potable
a las comunidades más carentes de
latinoamérica que progresos hay al
respecto y dónde están las principales
carencias
yo diría que las carencias buenos días
primero a todos ustedes y las carencias
de agua en nuestra américa latina están
en todas partes tanto en lugares urbanos
como en lugares rurales
y lo que estamos viendo no solamente es
escasez de agua sino una mala calidad de
agua y esto se debe a una serie de
factores número uno que nuestros
gobiernos nacionales y locales no le han
dado tanta importancia al manejo de el
agua no han dado suficiente atención a
la importancia de traer nuevas
tecnologías que nos permitan en los
hogares en el campo en la agricultura
ser más eficientes en el consumo de agua
y nos encontramos entonces con una
situación tremenda e inaceptable en el
planeta y es que una tercera parte del
agua que se utiliza por ejemplo en la
agricultura es desperdiciada y eso es
inaceptable verdad porque porque ya
estamos viendo en otros continentes
cuáles son las consecuencias de no tener
un adecuado manejo y políticas que
permitan a todos los ciudadanos ser
parte de la solución de mbe en lugar de
ser parte de un problema tan amenazante
a la vida
bueno yolanda mientras que en algunos
lugares se desperdicia cuáles son esos
países donde existe una verdadera
escasez de agua y cómo se puede
contrarrestar esa ausencia
yo diría que la escasez está en todos
nuestros países si es que no ha sido un
tradicional es escasez estamos viendo
que está apareciendo por ejemplo en en
chile donde el donde ha habido desiertos
tradicionalmente conocidos estamos
viendo que se extiende la
desertificación en zonas donde hay un
abuso del suelo por la agricultura la
siembra del aguacate por ejemplo está
creando un suelo es tremendamente
degradado se están absorbiendo la
humedad y el agua subterránea y eso
lleva a la desertificación lo mismo
sucede en mi país en el ecuador ya
tenemos nosotros inmigrantes ambientales
por por la escasez de agua y la
desertificación de sus suelos entonces
es obvio que la población se va a
territorios donde encuentran mayores de
opciones sobre todo para la producción
agrícola y para la sobrevivencia
bueno sigamos hablando sobre eso porque
en medio de la pandemia
precisamente las afectaciones no
solamente son para las personas son
directamente para el planeta donde están
esos principales gritos de auxilio
en una américa latina
[Música]
a ver yo diría en los antes sobre todo
porque estamos viendo un impacto
tremendo de cambio climático que es la
disminución del tamaño de los glaciares
y son los glaciares los que alimentan de
agua a nuestros páramos ya nuestras
zonas andinas y a los ríos no es cierto
que también fluyen hacia hacia el mar
pero en estas zonas de páramo y de
sierra andina estamos viendo ya una
escasez que afecta gravemente y se
convierte en una amenaza importante y es
un problema global es un problema claire
planetario pero yo siento que en
nuestros países latinoamericanos todavía
nos falta mucho para entender que esa
amenaza del cambio climático es bastante
master ya que aquella que estamos
viviendo en este momento del cobi es una
amenaza donde los impactos van a ser tan
graves que no vamos a poderlos manejar
en un año o dos como esperamos manejar
el tema de este virus
pues muchísimas gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros una responsabilidad
muy importante para la sociedad civil
para los emprendedores y para los
empresarios para proteger este recurso
vital sigan con nosotros en france 24
[Música]